WITH BRAND-NEW CNN POLLING
PAINTING THE PICTURE OF AN
ELECTORATE THAT IS BOTH DIVIDED
AND DEPRESSED AHEAD OF THIS
NOVEMBER'S MIDTERM ELECTIONS.
STRAIGHT TO POLITICAL DIRECTOR
WHO IS BREAKING IT DOWN FOR US.
DAVID?
>> ABBY, WE HAVE THESE BRAND-NEW
CNN POLLING NUMBERS CONDUCTED
LOOKING AT THE MID-TERM
ELECTORATE.
LET'S START WITH WHAT WE CALL
THE GENERIC CONGRESSIONAL
BALLOT.
LOOK AT THESE NUMBERS THIS IS A
TIED RACE AT THE MOMENT.
46% OF VOTERS IN THE POLL SAY
THEY PREFER THE REPUBLICAN
CANDIDATE IN THE MID-TERM
ELECTION.
46% DEMOCRAT.
I DO WANT TO CAUTION HERE, THIS
IS A SCORE THAT POLLSTERS
NORMALLY BELIEVE DEMOCRATS NEED
TO ACTUALLY BE AHEAD ON IF THEY
ARE GOING TO PICK UP SEATS.
SO A TIE IN THIS GENERIC
CONGRESSIONAL BALLOT USUALLY
DOES BENEFIT THE REPUBLICANS
HERE.
THIS IS NOT A NUMBER DEMOCRATS
SEE AND SAY, OH, WE'RE GOING TO
BE FINE IN THE MIDTERMS, BUT IT
DOES SHOW A COMPETITIVE CONTEST,
PERHAPS MORE COMPETITIVE THAN
THE OVERALL POLITICAL
ENVIRONMENT WOULD SUGGEST.
AND TAKE A LOOK AT IT OVER TIME
HERE.
BACK IN JANUARY AND FEBRUARY
DEMOCRATS WERE DOWN AT 43% IN
THIS.
THEY WERE AT 44% IN APRIL AND
MAY.
DOWN AT 42%.
THEY'RE NOW UP TO 46%.
SO DEMOCRATS HAVE SEEN A LITTLE
BIT OF A BUMP PERHAPS COINCIDING
WITH THE SUPREME COURT
OVERTURNING ROE VS. WADE AND
THAT ENERGIZING SOME DEMOCRATS.
AS FOR THE ISSUES THAT ARE
DRIVING THIS RACE, ABBY, THE
ECONOMY IS ISSUE NUMBER ONE.
51% OF AMERICANS IN THIS POLL
SAY THEY WANT TO HEAR FROM
CONGRESSIONAL CANDIDATES ABOUT
THE ECONOMY.
LOOK WHEN YOU SPLIT BY PARTY.
OVERWHELMINGLY ON THE REPUBLICAN
SIDE, 71% SAY THEY WANT TO HEAR
CANDIDATES TALK ABOUT THE
ECONOMY AND INFLATION.
NOTHING ELSE REALLY BREAKS THE
DOUBLE DIGITS, OKAY.
NOW LOOK AT THE DEMOCRATIC SIDE.
IT'S MORE OF A SMORGASBORD OF
TOPICS DEMOCRATIC VOTERS ARE
LOOK TO GO HEAR FROM
CONGRESSIONAL CANDIDATES ON.
YES, ECONOMY AND INFLATION STILL
UP ON TOP, 32%.
GUN POLICY, 23%.
VOTING AND ELECTIONS, 15%.
ABORTION DOWN AT 10%.
SO THIS IS STILL AN ELECTORATE
THAT IS LOOKING TO HEAR ABOUT
THE ECONOMY BUT OVERWHELMINGLY
FOR REPUBLICANS MORE OF A MIX
FOR DEMOCRATS.
AND THE OTHER THING WE LOOK FOR
IS WHO HAS THE EDGE ON
ENTHUSIASM, BECAUSE IT'S ONE
THING TO LOOK AT REGISTERED
VOTERS.
IT'S ANOTHER THING WHO IS GOING
TO SHOW UP.
AND ONE OF THE WAYS WE EXPLORE
THAT WHO IS MORE ENTHUSIASTIC
ABOUT VOTING.
LOOK AT THESE NUMBERS HERE.
THE REPUBLICANS HAVE A
SEVEN-POINT ADVANTAGE OVER THE
DEMOCRATS IN TERMS OF BEING
EXTREMELY ENTHUSIASTIC TO VOTE.
35% OF REPUBLICANS SAY SO.
28% OF DEMOCRATS.
YOU SEE THAT HAS BEEN AN
ADVANTAGE IN ALL OF THE POLLING
THIS YEAR FOR REPUBLICANS AND
YOU SEE HOW IT TICKS UP AS THE
YEAR GOES ON.
MORE AND MORE PEOPLE ARE GETTING
ENTHUSIASTIC ABOUT VOTING BUT,
AGAIN, THIS IS A SIGNIFICANT
ADVANTAGE, SEVEN PERCENTAGE
POINTS HERE FOR THE REPUBLICANS
ON THAT SCORE.
>> AND THERE'S SO MUCH TO BREAK
DOWN IN ALL OF THAT.
HERE TO SHARE THE REPORTING AND
INSIGHTS WHITE HOUSE REPORTER OF
THE ASSOCIATED PRESS , NPR HOST
ALICIA ROSCOE AND EARLY 202
CO-AUTHOR AT THE "WASHINGTON
POST" LEIGH ANN CALDWELL.
THAT GENERIC BALLOT I CAN'T GET
OUT OF MY HEAD IN PART BECAUSE
OF WHAT DAVID SHOWED US, HOW
IT'S CHANGED OVER TIME.
WE ARE IN A BASICALLY
HEAD-TO-HEAD BATTLE BETWEEN
DEMOCRATS AND REPUBLICANS.
THIS ELECTION THE ENVIRONMENT
SEEMS TO BE SO FAVORABLE TO THE
REPUBLICAN PARTY.
INFLATION IS HIGH.
PEOPLE'S ECONOMIC SENTIMENTS ARE
INCREDIBLY LOW.
THERE'S A FEELING OF
UNSETTLEDNESS IN THE ELECTORATE,
AND YET THIS LOOKS LIKE IT'S
GOING TO BE A FIGHT.
>> ESPECIALLY WITH PRESIDENT
BIDEN'S LOW POLL NUMBERS AND
STILL DEMOCRATS WERE TIED WITH
REPUBLICANS IN THE GENERIC
BALLOT.
AND THAT'S WHAT WAS SO
SURPRISING TO ME.
BUT DIGGING DEEPER INTO THE
POLLS, DAVID, AS YOU'VE LAID
OUT, PEOPLE ARE FRUSTRATED WITH
GOVERNMENT.
THEY ARE FRUSTRATED WITH BOTH
PARTIES.
THEY WANT THE ECONOMY TO GET
BETTER.
AND THEY DON'T HAVE A VERY
OPTIMISTIC VIEW OF THE FUTURE.
BUT THE FACT THAT DEMOCRATS ARE
TIED WITH REPUBLICANS IN THIS
GENERIC BALLOT IS VERY GOOD NEWS
FOR DEMOCRATS WHO HAVE BEEN VERY
CONCERNED ABOUT THE MIDTERM
ELECTIONS.
>> AND I WOULD JUST NOTE TO THIS
POINT ABOUT THE PRESIDENT'S
NUMBERS BEING DOWN BUT BEING
TIED WHAT IS SO INTERESTING WHEN
YOU LOOK IN OUR POLL IS THAT 19%
OF PEOPLE WHO SAY THEY
DISAPPROVE OF THE JOB PRESIDENT
BIDEN IS DOING, THEY'RE STILL
VOTING FOR A DEMOCRAT ON THE
GENERIC CONGRESSIONAL BALLOT.
THAT IS THE MISSION FOR THIS
WHITE HOUSE AND THIS PARTY IS TO
TAKE PEOPLE WHO ARE EXPRESSING
ALL OF THIS DISSATISFACTION WITH
BIDEN'S LEADERSHIP AND
PERFORMANCE BECAUSE OF THE
ECONOMY AND WHAT HAVE YOU, AND
HAVE THEM CAST A BALLOT FOR THE
DEMOCRATS.
ONE IN FIVE DISAPPROVERS OF
BIDEN ARE DOING THAT IN THIS
POLL.
>> THIS IS WHAT IS SO
FASCINATING ABOUT THE
ENVIRONMENT, THIS IS BY ALL
ACCOUNTS THE REPUBLICAN PARTY'S
RACE TO LOSE WITH THE PRESIDENT
AT 38% AND YET YOU SEE VOTERS
KIND OF BASICALLY SAYING WE SEE
BOTH PARTIES KIND OF ALONG THE
SAME LINES.
ONE THING I THOUGHT WAS
INTERESTING WE HAVE A PART OF
THE POLL HERE THAT ASKS WHETHER
CANDIDATES HAVE, IN THEIR AREA,
HAVE THEIR PRIORITIES AT THE TOP
OF THEIR MIND.
AND BASICALLY VOTERS SAY THE
DEMOCRATIC CANDIDATES, 67%, NO.
65% SAY NO ABOUT REPUBLICANS.
THEY DON'T LIKE ANY OF THESE
PEOPLE.
>> AND IT KIND OF MAKES SENSE.
YOU CAN'T REALLY BLAME PEOPLE.
WHEN YOU LOOK AT THE ECONOMY,
THE BIG ISSUE IS INFLATION.
WHAT CAN THE GOVERNMENT REALLY
DO ABOUT THAT?
AND THE FACT IS THERE'S NOT MUCH
THAT THEY CAN DO ON EITHER
PARTY.
THE REPUBLICANS DON'T HAVE A
PLAN TO FIX INFLATION.
THEY ARE BENEFITTING FROM BEING
ABLE TO JUST CALL OUT THE
PROBLEMS, BUT THEY DON'T HAVE A
SOLUTION TO FIX IT.
AND, REALLY, THERE IS A BIGGER
PROBLEM FOR DEMOCRACY HERE IN
THAT PEOPLE DO NOT FEEL LIKE THE
GOVERNMENT IS ANSWERING THEIR
NEEDS.
AND WHEN YOU LOOK AT CONGRESS
AND YOU LOOK AT HOW THINGS GET
STALLED AND HOW CONGRESS IS
UNABLE TO DO THE BIG THINGS, YOU
CAN'T REALLY ARGUE WITH PEOPLE
ON THAT.
THEY'RE NOT REALLY HANDLING THE
ISSUES.
THAT'S JUST A FACT.
>> AND YET FAR AND AWAY, IF YOU
LOOK AT THE POLLS AND THE
NUMBERS IN OUR POLL AND THE
NUMBERS IN A LOT OF OTHER POLLS,
THE NUMBER ONE ISSUE FOR VOTERS
IS THE ECONOMY.
IT IS BY FAR A BIGGER ISSUE IF
YOU'RE A REPUBLICAN-LEANING
VOTER.
IT'S STILL THE TOP ISSUE EVEN
FOR DEMOCRATIC-LEANING VOTERS.
AND THOSE VOTERS ALSO SAY,
ACCORDING TO OUR POLL, THAT THEY
THINK 54% SAY REPUBLICANS WOULD
BE BETTER AT HANDLING ECONOMIC
ISSUES COMPARED TO A LOT OF
OTHER ISSUES.
SO THAT IS STILL A PROBLEM FOR
PRESIDENT BIDEN AND THE
DEMOCRATS TO SOLVE FOR.
>> YOU'VE SEEN ACTUALLY A PRETTY
AGGRESSIVE MESSAGING FRONT
COMING FROM THE WHITE HOUSE OVER
THE LAST FEW DAYS.
TRYING TO, FIRST OF ALL, REMIND
THE PUBLIC THAT AT LEAST FOR THE
LAST SEVERAL WEEKS THAT GAS
PRICES HAVE GONE DOWN
DRAMATICALLY.
WE DON'T KNOW WHETHER THEY ARE
DROPPING AND HERE TO STAY OR
NOT, BUT REALLY TRYING TO BE OUT
THERE AND TELLING THAT THINGS --
WE HEAR YOU.
THINGS ARE TOUGH RIGHT NOW.
ON THIS FRONT GAS PRICES AT
LEAST FOR NOW ARE IMPROVING AND
HERE ARE ALL THE OTHER THINGS
WE'RE DOING TO IMPROVE THE
ECONOMIC SITUATION FOR VOTERS.
BUT BECAUSE THEY DO KNOW THAT
THIS IS THEIR BIGGEST LIABILITY
HEADING INTO THE MIDTERMS THIS
FALL AND WE'RE TALKING ABOUT THE
ISSUES NOW.
WHAT I FOUND INTERESTING WHAT
ELSE FROM THAT CNN POLL WHILE
OBVIOUSLY THE ECONOMY AND
INFLATION TOOK THE TOP BILLING
FOR WHAT IS IMPORTANT TO VOTERS,
ABORTION WAS ACTUALLY A LITTLE
BIT LOWER ON THE LIST THAN I
THOUGHT WOULD HAPPEN.
>> EVEN FOR DEMOCRATS.
>> IT WAS NOT RATING FOR
REPUBLICANS VERY MUCH BUT FOR
DEMOCRATS IT WAS PRETTY LOW.
>> RIGHT.
>> ON THAT POINT, THOUGH, TAKE A
LOOK AT THIS.
ASKED ABOUT WHETHER THE PARTY'S
VIEWS ON ABORTION ARE TOO
EXTREME OR MAINSTREAM, VOTERS
OVERWHELMINGLY SAY THE DEMOCRATS
ARE IN THE MAINSTREAM AND THAT
REPUBLICANS ARE TOO EXTREME ON
THE ISSUE OF ABORTION.
DAVID CHALIAN, WHAT DOES THAT
SAY TO YOU?
>> IT EXPLAINS WHY WE'RE SEEING
A LOT OF DEMOCRATIC CANDIDATES
LEANING INTO THIS ISSUE OF A
WOMAN'S RIGHT TO CHOOSE AND
PRIVACY RIGHTS AND ALL OF THE
AFTERMATH OF THE DECISION THAT
CAME DOWN FROM THE SUPREME COURT
OVERTURNING ROE V. WADE AS A
PRINCIPLE PART OF THEIR CAMPAIGN
MESSAGING BECAUSE OF ALL THE
ISSUES WE TESTED, ABBY, IT'S
ONLY THAT ISSUE THAT A MAJORITY
SEES ONE OF THE PARTIES AS TOO
EXTREME, IN THIS CASE ON
ABORTION, 55% SAY THE
REPUBLICANS ARE TOO EXTREME ON
THIS ISSUE.
THAT'S THE ONLY ONE THAT SCORE
THAT IS WAY AS A MAJORITY OF
AMERICANS RESPOND LOOKING AT THE
PARTIES ON ALL THE GIVEN ISSUES
WE TESTED.
>> AND THAT'S WHY YOU SEE
DEMOCRATS ON CAPITOL HILL
HOLDING VOTES THIS WEEK AND
TRYING TO HOLD VOTES LAST WEEK
ON SOME OF THESE ISSUES TO PAINT
REPUBLICANS AS EXTREME.
THEY'RE GOING TO VOTE ON ACCESS
TO CONTRACEPTION.
THEY'RE ALSO GOING TO VOTE ON A
SAME-SEX MARRIAGE CODIFICATION
BILL TODAY.
IT MIGHT GET THE SUPPORT OF SOME
REPUBLICANS.
BUT THEY DO WANT TO PUT
REPUBLICANS ON THE RECORD ON
WHERE THEY STAND ON THESE ISSUES
AND TRY TO PAINT SOME OF THESE
REPUBLICANS AS EXTREME.
>> WHICH IS AN ODD THING TO SEE
DEMOCRATS LEANING INTO CULTURAL
ISSUES AND FORCING --
>> THIS ELECTION MAY NOT TURN ON
CULTURAL ISSUES, BUT IT SEEMS
BASED ON THIS POLL THAT THERE IS
A BRAND PROBLEM FOR THE
REPUBLICAN PARTY RIGHT NOW THAT
THEY HAVE TO DEAL WITH.